I'm going to find a quicker I have a lot
of content but vitamin e online
afterwards I'm having to take questions
so this type of quote no sequel and see
both getting to have it all my subtitle
to this is my guide to a totally fun
crazy scalable so first let me introduce
myself frankly I prefer hanging rails
almost pointed that way back in 2005 I
went back and looked at the email and
when I did it was great oh boy 13 which
was 80 kilobytes of total awesomeness
rails for one and 72 times bigger
recently been doing some architecture
and code and operations and management i
was at script for a while it was a top
one her website in the world one of the
biggest rail sites out there then it was
over a culture
about 7 million users Naaman Swift type
Swift type is site search in a box as a
service so stops on your site searched
you may be tempted to install solar
electric search which actually is a lot
harder than you think it is I even come
to subscribe and set up for you we're
selling we're also hiring so that's my
blood no my interests are rails at large
like how many rail the convicts lots of
developers lots of code base high
complexity not necessarily standing
committees which all that's often part
of it the chinese i'm going to show you
here tonight have been proven and like
we use them at several different
companies at like hundred million rows
or more so this is not an experimental
ideas that they may or may not work
there's great place for those this is
real style so this is talk for this is
for basically anybody who's messing
around with four data layer in your
application anybody touches it in any
way this is for business data you're
acting we just about anything so
traditional single you know HTML other
than multi page apps a single piece of
JavaScript app contain a mobile app
trail api's all this touches for data
since is applicable to any of that this
also works for both brands applications
that are totally green field or like
grizzled old giant whales code bases
I've seen a few of those so I'm going to
talk about before businesses that's what
is that is applicable to so what does
that mean for facility that is things
like users accounts permissions
stuff like this it's also stuff like
email preferences a t-test assignments
you to block other users if anything
can't really check on your application
without that's my definition of for
business data it is not things like web
logs behavioral analysis data audit
trails that stuff this stuff is
typically done an offline that's a
completely different talk it's also not
like large objects so if you're viewing
like you know giant videos in the
database or graphically you're mirroring
facebook social graph don't listen to me
tonight instead go badly so where do we
put this stuff traditionally we have two
choices to the relational database we're
in the sequel database that's today exit
traditionally five years ago with just
relational databases if you choose a
relational database you get a lot of
stuff for free that people often don't
think about you get acid transactions
you can allow the operational
flexibility so it's equal with
relational databases you can like have
slaves and streaming backups of all
kinds of stuff that we kind of take for
granted there's a really robust
ecosystem physically only a few players
in relational database world you can
find consultants and books and training
and what happened you'll fit the way of
learning efficient storage that in terms
of your your actual data the store is on
this and one
memory is quite compact the reason
people started looking away from
relational databases I think for core
business data is it you also have a lot
to give up typically a limited data
types you don't like sometimes you want
to store like a hash of arrays and
patches of arrays or something crazy
like that you just can't do that in any
straightforward manner in the relational
databases readily you have like strings
and complaints and games and stuff like
that you have a heavyweight schema
you've got one migrations there a big
deal that be careful and you might have
some scalability concerns like is this a
basement support what I needed in sport
mover the no sequel I would have a lot
of people do this because it fixes a lot
of those Western flexible data types so
you can store any kind of crazy you have
no migration is typically which is
awesome and hopefully a better skater
that's a lovely promise on for sequel
the thing is that you actually give up a
lot of this other stuff too many many no
sequel data storage support transactions
at all which I would argue is a huge
huge deal deployments and support like
the no civil community is currently
really fragmented into a lot of
different pieces and there's no map
couple dominant player like there are
relational database world so no matter
which one you pick you may not be able
to find community that's leaving the
relation
that's a big deal there's also been
certainly less efficient storage a lot
of this stuff is done in JSON or similar
data facts which have no internet so
tonight what I'm going to show you is
I'm going to talking to three parts the
first part is going to show you how to
deal with this problem limited data
types and a heavyweight schema in a
relational database and how to improve
its how easily develop on top of it in
that way secondly going to discuss is
efficient storage it's actually the make
your relational thing to explore is even
more efficient which when you're using
its a developer is a big win and then
the final one is scale building in terms
of an address how do you scale
relational database in a way to don't
work so in order to do this i'm going to
introduce a user's table i'll come back
to the several times it's not like you
need to memorize it this is sort of
amalgam of a user's table I see over the
years this is not you know there's no
phone company that has its users table I
put a bunch of different stuff in there
that's pretty typical my main point is
this is not the light rail 101 wolf
flight home user table it's really nice
and simple this is more
I think people actually have it
production again I come back to it the
first thing I talk about it's going to
use on in your relational database and
especially a few years ago this is like
oh mine really well this used to be
heresy and part of my point tonight is
there's not actually a reason not to
store some data this way if you're
careful and come right tools so what is
being carefully being careful means you
only have our store data in jigs on your
relational database that you won't ever
Imperium because generally you can't do
it and I know the posters fans out there
are like oh yeah you can impose best and
that's really cool but there's still a
lot of limitations on it in general I
would prefer not have the query on data
Jake's on field also this is I think a
point that's less obvious you only work
with data in Jake's on that unique of
one row at a time so taking our users
cake say we're going to show users to 11
years this is a really common thing for
a lot of system let me show you pages 35
other users and you want to whatever if
you're going to put say pictures on the
screen don't store the users profile URL
in this JSON the law because then just
let this 35 users use JSON get out
serialize it all
once that's pretty expensive the other
big deals don't ever store default in a
day sun block this is easy to do oh it
was a bunch of default values all state
database you can end up with a table
that has like 100 million rows of JSON
logs that have been vaccinated over and
over and over again that's a nightmare
anybody where would we had a particular
company that won't
experienced this problem it's not fun so
let's go back to our users table given
those criteria what are the new use for
a JSON storm there's some stuff in 10
it's pretty obvious like locale user
what language do they want to see our
side we only have to look at that for
they currently logged in user or
probably not never been a query on that
if we do it's not that big a deal like
that simply not a mission-critical query
so that's a good candidate a couple
other things that are less obvious so
you have paper oh also concerned
database and maybe a strike to open for
customer records again we only deal with
that with the currently blocking user
we're not going to slip this out both a
period on them the final one that I
think is actually once I knew as a sort
of staring at me right in the face it's
a password finish that's a great
candidate your only local password for
the currently logged in user you touch
it rarely you never periodic you bridge
anyway so all four of those things can
go on our JSON data store so how do you
do this there's an obvious way to do
this and I know it's like a cartoon to
that type holidays I go through a little
you basically take your users table you
add a text column that's going to be
your takes on store you might make a
video with that left out of here you
drop your own coffee so now everything
to json store right and is this tool at
the record store that comes with rate of
these days the less you basically make
of akwa attributes on your act record
model and serializing mister lies
adjacent really easily so set up for
none except not quite so you look and
see what you've really done if you've
done this we remove five standard
columns with added one json store with
its contents embedded 85 bicycle repent
every single row which doesn't sound
like lots of users and then it's a big
big deal and so most of the fights our
district all names of data into json
scores just like basic oh also get it
repeated 100 million times this is not
only this is loaded every single time
your cheek music
any meat let's try this again there's a
gem out there that published called flex
columns and here's something to do with
that will be a separate table for the
trey songz computer details it's got two
columns user ID and the JSON clock each
one to one with the users table we're
gonna add later there i'm going to
remove it from these articles drop those
columns entirely we have a select
columns them and it has a little dsl for
defining the language for these columns
will do a one the one with the user and
I'm compensating the flex towns from and
what this does is it makes the
attributes in this JSON passions
actually living in another table show up
directly on the user as if they were
attributes of that user directly you
still can't pretty on them but you can
achieve any of the rest of your code
nothing else knows
selling out on your model directly and
working at this point we're only going
to happen though that JSON store from
this and ship it across the network and
P serialize it for those few attributes
that we only ever use for like the
currently logged-in user this is
actually a big planet there's one more
thing we're going to do this jeff has
quietly features one of them is that we
can define the names of the columns to
be used in the JSON score 17 cutting in
the application i'm going to say in the
application online posting a photograph
in the database is called pw provoke
alcohol at velvet so for this is the
kind of thing that kind of seems dumb
except again we both want this 500
million rows you've actually reduce the
overhead a great deal that makes a big
difference in your database one more set
of stuff the quicks film does is a lot
of features in there but just to make
sure that it also does transparent gzip
compression store things like HTML in
your databases to make a huge difference
of helping your ex rows are except for
validation support even some horses kind
of tanks that are and looks like active
record database types it will remove no
longer
move the field it will go clean up the
stop adding state back out you think
some patches later it also supports
radio was three point out to 4.1 any
remotely recent version groovy engine
Ruby my sequel of us dread sequel like
Emily an industrial-strength person
inaccurately story so that's the first
second thing I have to make your
relational database a little bit more
like another sequel database and be able
to use it much more flexibly cognisance
for things like access to the rates of
patches in there do whatever you want
second technique I'm going to call low
carb Nellie tables this is also familiar
face for some nights for anybody it's
done see ended meals so what's
cardinality cardinality is the number of
distinct values in column holes so a
high cardinality columns something like
username or email address or first name
username email address i'll use every
user it's different first name it's not
unique but there's a lot of different
things out there right slow carnality is
stuff like deleted that's a cool game
gender let's take place with gender
thing is having different values for
gender but it's still pretty low
cardinality compact like 100 million
users there's also like your admin leave
you have for mmm those are all low
cardinality columns and what they can
look at it we're almost always throwing
those is full column why are we using an
entire column like one min flat
exploring like the orbits coming back to
our users table I think is actually
pretty typical if you look at which
columns in our users take or a little
cardinality is actually quite a lot of
them in this case it's almost a third of
the table in my experience is pretty
typical you have lots and lots of flag
from the user
ways I'm not going to go to all the
right here but suffice to say i think
it's pretty straightforward these are
always homes and like flags or mean them
in some way what can we do with this
with this little part cables get here's
what we're going to do we're gonna clean
you take call user statuses I can't
believe the work status for this you can
call anyone into migration we say low
card goes the truth this creates a table
with exactly the columns I'm going to
pull off the user fee we're gonna create
a model for if there's a lot of our
table we're going to tell the tell the
user class that has its little party so
what is it's done this is not doing what
you may think it's doing this actually
oh that would make one more point when
we pull this out there looking to do is
take things like gender and formal level
and instead of storing these integers
when the store them sexual strength it's
really annoying like oh you know for a
little second what does that maybe or
gender value is 17 I can no idea what
that means the number of times I had to
go into a database and like slide out
first names and
to figure out which one which means
female was kind of ridiculous I'm going
to stuff is strings here's what's
actually happening this local our table
done is going to create one row in the
local art table for each unique
combination of flags from the users
table automatically so as your story
users it's going to populate this table
automatically by saying hey is there is
he's there the combination I need in
there already if so use it otherwise
co-created and it's not going to users
people we're just having pointers back
to this so you look like the first road
safe okay user ID one has a new status i
can tweet that that would be no that
very schultz is female not at all this a
beginner has a verify email and send a
newsletter to her because this is all
about the demand to any combinations of
data you don't actually have
theoretically could exist but you don't
actually have never end up in this table
so we don't have like saving never sent
a newsletter to not verify email
addresses sounds reasonable there are no
accommodations a false and true pin here
so we create just the road from me it's
kind of efficient as you can possibly
get this is sort of describe what i just
said in text or did it work generally
grows on the man this is a big deal so
what we do at one time is actually
conscious entire table in them this only
has a few hundred rose now rail is going
to operate anything incredibly quickly
and a production stable state against 0
ever pretty rapidly end up with an every
combination you're going to have them
there and it's all sitting in memory and
it all does there's lots of stuff in
there to handle database blocking so
multiple processes try to create the
same about the same time you don't want
the problems it all works it's also we
horse-trade court will see prompt if
you're sitting an actual my seeking
counsel or bus best console trying to
figure out what's going on with this
he's way better than if you actually try
to implement big deal to your database
where you have a giant integer that
you're trans brake down into like these
orbits and stuff like that also the last
point I'll make indexes on boolean
fields typically are useful in store
database we won't use it index the
lesson thinks it's been a narrow it down
to a very small percentage of roses a
full table scan it's cheaper that's
still true you're going to look for like
all you know not only the users in your
database there's nothing is going to
help there but if you're looking for
particular combinations like I want
deleted anonymous users who are still
getting the email for some reason the
index may actually be able to help here
and that's pretty great so how does this
look from rails the short version is it
all works exactly like you'd expect he
acts exactly like was a real
gender validations defaults goes with
class level scopes the validations on
the status cake instead it kind of mixed
up wherever you want a few last basis of
this there's also full full full support
I've often had a phone like I import
users in back to 200,000 their API that
lets you sort of collect those users
then very opportunely one or two queries
it will find and then create all the
values in the little parking Whitney's
handle the eight guys were partially
reads as active support notifications if
you want to watch what's happening this
it also supports every decent person
rails and some not so recent versions
Ruby in JRuby again my sequel ah stress
sequel light both these dems actually
oxyle work with things like Oracle and
sequel server hydras actually have
private impedances of workload sequel
server at night I don't know how many
valence dollars on assessed against nor
is there a lot of the man that so glass
piece I'm going to show is how they can
you pull this together how we
synthesizers um so when I rail only
support one database but we know that's
not so many right that's that's settled
welcome accent that there's no reason to
keep everything one thing to make sit
down mexican surprise still genius i'm
going to do see to a gentle DB charmer
this is not written by me this is
written by a guy named Alexei covering
who's kind of the most amazing person
different companies you can't have him
he's ours stay away so little models
look like a bee bee charmer DD
tournaments you say on any rails ok TV
magic is the key word for it here's the
connection this is something just a
natural database that yeah Melissa where
introducers master database where does
it live automatic carbon want now
queries for any users on a lot of I
could go to that database what's really
cool those but also to find slaves work
if you have some my sequins lace across
their slaves and say this is me replica
of that it will automatically route all
queries round-robin among the slaves
unless you're like an intense action and
then automatically knows Germans
actually be better talk to the master
it's also got a ton of really cool
syntax like in a good way that lets you
grab the greys however you want so you
can create scopes and then you can say
okay this scope is always using the
master you can be mapped databases into
all kinds of stuff
basically what I just said the last
point I'll make your TV drama has
processed I connected the map hundreds
of billions of queries without a problem
although strippers don't run a bee
charmer I mean this was it's typically
do 2003 the second plus all the time so
this isn't a gentleman it's me I need
something I can trust to build a
business on top of this is something i
can actually trust I think I let's use
not always in all ways as we're
promoting its economic reform it's
pretty solid let's talk a little bit
about how we allocate these decreases so
now we have aspects ability to put
models where we want when we do with
that here's what we're going to jump in
production our universe people we're
going to live on a server in a lot of
RAM let us learn in fact that the entire
users table animals indexes just get
cash in ranch persistently this means
it's going to serve straight out of
brand never need to touch the visiting
separate rights this is really really
fast this is how you get thousands of
queries per second without a problem and
as it turns out using these tools one
thing we've done is broken apart of our
users people into enough pieces that I
did the back of that sample users table
you can let the server amazon
for 24 bucks a month thinking cast
hundred eighteen million users in its
memory is one of the high memory
instances to using these tools you can
add up with the server that's really
cheap they can scale to a huge number of
users our details this is our base on
block this is known as a server that
doesn't need to have the much RAM
because it's going to hit this every
time you access it but that's okay
because only accessing it for the
currently logged in user it's a
one-to-one kind of key value stores sort
of thing that's not about at all and in
this low cardinality table that we have
this thing can do it anywhere because
you're basically never ever query in
fact your typical career dragon is going
to be when you deploy at least our rails
instances they will hit this once to
load up in the memory and then it's it
that's our like production deployment
and so for each major cable in the
system you would kind of love something
like this except that that's you really
leaving assembly TV production database
is over here these can snack on top of
each other when you're just starting out
you don't want to buy a ton of
infrastructure you want to do something
like this so you can stack these JSON
blob on the same server you can throw I
can all look Parnelli tables
just one place and what I would actually
do is buy single server and put creep
database database is between one server
instance oh you like one my sequel da
one poster scheming but then you've got
multiple databases within it this makes
sure that you're not joining between
instances unnecessarily trap all those
errors right off the bat you're not
actually spending any more time on
harbor management some of them come back
and say wrap up this topic took my right
there why are you doing this talk coming
back to the slide here's my fundamental
pieces i watch people pick out they
destruction of their applications my
personal opinion is that losing this
stuff is way more painful than you
realize you come in in your life okay no
big deal like I get it has a lot to You
Lily features that's awesome
transactions in particular can be a very
painful thing to move deployments and
support like all this stuff is really
adds up I'm not saying don't use a no
sequel database I'm saying be really
careful before you do that and with you
know what you're getting into if you're
for you know if you're building a
business in front of their for circle
innovation of your business is dealing
with vast amounts of data by all means
you may or really something makes maybe
a terrible idea for you but I think a
lot of people are building something
they're like hey our for innovation is
not in data storage itself is it
something else to work doing and I think
giving this stuff up be pretty painful
the tools
tonight and really help out I'm not
saying thanks every problem with the
world and pretty but it's really helped
out a lot of this stuff over here and
make relational databases ways to use
and one looks fun to use as it develops
so lastly guess my talk